back in November an international team
of scientists stunned the world by
landing a spacecraft on a comet the fill
a lander spent ten years traveling to
the comet since completing its journey
it has been sending incredible images
back to earth i'm here at a German
Aerospace Center in Cologne behind me is
the Mission Control Center where
scientists controlled the feeling Lander
before it ran out of battery power the
craft successful landing was a proud
moment for the man leading the project
Stefan elements what does this landing
mean to you as the technical director of
the project it was the first time ever
landing on a comet and we have been
working for this now for 20 years it's
certainly a highlight in the career and
also in the personal life outside Stefan
Ulla Mets says the comet will get closer
to the Sun in the coming months meaning
its solar panels will receive more
energy that should allow the lander to
recharge its batteries but experts need
to work out its location on the comet to
make sense of the data the photos from
the comet are being analyzed at the Max
Planck Institute for solar system
research team leader holger's x explains
why it so hard to find the fillet Lander
mrs. earth is responsible for the search
of land or feel a it touched down the
first time here and then it's jumped
away and nobody knows where it is now no
or do you know so the lander touched
down at this point this is the first
contact point and after one second
already it left this side so we have the
impression we have seen a dot passing
here and the final rest position is in
this area well the search area is about
500 x 500 meters so well it's a one
little dot 2 meter by meter for the
lander so it's quite challenging to find
the lender
the latest photos of the area the lander
is believed to be in may contain the
answer we have a hard time finding the
lender here it's hiding well in in a
gravel field so this could be the lander
perhaps this could also be the land
areas but you see they are very common
so big dots and you're careful now no
well it's it's very hard to claim this
as the lander is this the lander is that
the landris so we need definitely be
more more data but some of the
scientists involved in the project can
continue their work without knowing the
Landers location does the water on earth
come from comets so far we there are two
competing series 1 series aims the
Comets have brought this water mainly
other series claim that the asteroids
are a particular source which have
brought the water to earth at the moment
we think it's highly unlikely that the
comets are the origin of the water which
we are drinking here together were smile
is looking for amino acids in the water
they could give us information on the
origins of life on Earth so the question
is both types of amino acids both types
of life forming elements report by those
celestial body to us I think you can
expect in the next couple of months you
know first announcement from our
collaborations on our findings the
outcome of this mission can already be
described as groundbreaking landing on a
comet that's 500 million kilometers away
is a success in its own right in the
meantime the first spectacular results
reveal that european space exploration
is on the right path even with spares
funds the belly in europe project has
already provided scientists with
invaluable information and they're
hopeful that more will arrive from the
comet in 2015